Arnsberg im Hochsauerland es ist die
Heimat des Friedrich Merz und es ist der
Ort an dem der CDU-Vorsitzende die
Brandmauer seiner Partei endgültig ins
Wanken bringt im zdf-sommer Interview
erklärt märz die Zusammenarbeit mit der
AFD auf kommunaler Ebene für möglich wir
sind doch selbstverständlich
verpflichtet demokratische Wahlen zu
akzeptieren und wenn dort das noch mal
ein Landrat ein Bürgermeister gewählt
wird der der AFD angehört ist es
selbstverständlich dass man nach Wegen
sucht wie man dann in dieser Stadt
weiter arbeiten kann im Netz ist das
Entsetzen groß Rechtsruck und wäre den
Anfängen lauten die Hashtags und auch
aus der Partei selbst kommt klare Kritik
die AFD kennt nur dagegen und Spaltung
wo soll es dazu Zusammenarbeit geben die
CDU kann will und wird nicht mit einer
Partei zusammenarbeiten deren
Geschäftsmodell hat Spaltung und
Ausgrenzung ist so der Regierende
Bürgermeister von Berlin
und die stellvertretende
Bundesvorsitzende und Bildungsministerin
aus Schleswig-Holstein erklärt die
Beschlusslage ist klar und ich kann mir
für meine Partei nichts anderes
vorstellen keine Zusammenarbeit mit
Extremisten was sie meint ist der
Parteitagsbeschluss von 2018 in dem die
CDU jegliche Zusammenarbeit mit der AFD
ausschließt und den auch Friedrich Merz
immer wieder verteidigt hatte klares
Kalkül gerade in Zeiten wie diesen trägt
jede demokratische Partei und damit auch
jede demokratische Politiker
Verantwortung wenn es um die
Verteidigung der Demokratie geht und
wenn solche Aussagen alle drei Tage von
Friedrich Merz kommen muss man ganz klar
sagen dass er diese Verantwortung nicht
gerecht wird Friedrich Merz hat in
seinem Sommer Interview klar gemacht
dass die CDU weiter nach rechts rutschen
wird das was sich vor einer guten Woche
mit dem Generalsekretär in einer Person
festgemacht hat macht sich jetzt eben
auch thematisch fest tatsächlich folgt
März Erklärung einem Kurs der sich schon
in den letzten Wochen angedeutet hatte
erst die Rede von den Grünen als
Hauptgegner die Hauptgegner sein dann
der neue Generalsekretär Abteilung law
and order und vor einer Woche die
Forderung nach einem schärferen Kurs in
der Migrationspolitik und einer
Abschaffung des individualrechts auf
Asyl auch hier legte März gestern nach
das ist ein konstruktiver Beitrag wir
werden das in der Bundestagsfraktion
auch noch mal Vertiefen der Ton wird
also rauer die politische Richtung
klarer das Ziel die afd-zahlen runter zu
kriegen und die eigenen hoch doch ob der
Weg der richtige ist daran haben auch
innerhalb der CDU manche Zweifel
und nicht nur da sprechen wir über all
das jetzt mit dem Generalsekretär der
SPD Kevin Kühnert schönen guten Morgen
guten Morgen aus dem schönen Allgäu Herr
Kühnert sie haben die Äußerungen von
Friedrich Merz ja auch schon kommentiert
das Argument von Friedrich Merz ist ja
der Pragmatismus wir sein verpflichtet
demokratische Wahlen anzuerkennen sagt
er und dazu gehören auf unterster also
auf kommunaler Ebene auch mit den
Umfrage oder besser gesagt mit den
Wahlergebnissen der AFD umzugehen das
abzulehnen nach dem Motto hauptsache
nicht mit der AFD das ignoriert doch den
WählerInnen
sie sprechen die Passage in dem
sommerinterview von Friedrich Merz an
die mir am meisten Kopfzerbrechen
bereitet denn den Kurswechsel den eher
als Vorsitzender offensichtlich jetzt
für seine CDU anstrebt die baut er auf
einer totalbrüchige Argumentation auf er
sagt wir müssen doch demokratische
Wahlen anerkennen aber wer spricht denn
dagegen der Landkreis Sonneberg hat
jetzt einen AFD Landrat raguhnjeßnitz
hat jetzt einen AFD Bürgermeister die
AFD ist zu demokratischen Wahlen
zugelassen sie kann Mandate erringen Sie
ausfüllen hat alle parlamentarischen
Rechte sie profitiert aus der
Parteienfinanzierung nur auf eines hat
sie die alle anderen Parteien auch kein
Anrecht nämlich das politisch mit ihr
kooperiert wird dass sie Teil der
Mehrheiten vor Ort sein muss und genau
hier stößt Friedrich Merz rein und sagt
jetzt dass seine CDU vor Ort eben doch
mit der AFD nach Mehrheiten offenkundig
suchen kann und das ist der Tabubruch
und hier muss klar und deutlich
widersprochen werden aber Herr kühn hat
mancherorts weiß man doch gar nicht wie
man überhaupt gegen die oder ohne die
AFD eine Regierung bilden soll ist das
nicht ganz pragm atisch gesehen
teilweise unumgänglich
im Moment ist die Lage so in jedem
Landtag in Deutschland in jedem
Kommunalparlament gibt es Mehrheiten
ohne die AFD und März versucht sich
jetzt hier an Ablenkungsmanövern
natürlich kann man mit dem AFD Landrat
in Sonneberg und muss man auch nach der
Geschäftsordnung mit ihm über das
zustande kommen der Tagesordnung
beispielsweise im Kreistag sprechen
welche Anträge wann beraten werden aber
schauen wir uns doch einmal die Aufgaben
eines Landrates an es gibt übergeordnete
Aufgaben da geht es um die Erfüllung von
Vorschriften und von Gesetzen von Bund
und Ländern das muss der Landrat machen
er kann sogar disziplinarrechtlich
herangezogen werden wenn er das nicht
tut und das andere sind die inneren
Angelegenheiten eines Landkreises die
Aufstellung des Haushaltes und anderes
mehr schulträgerschaften das entscheidet
der Kreistag mit seiner Mehrheiten
nirgendwo steht geschrieben dass das
alles im Einvernehmen mit dem Landrat
oder mit den Abgeordneten der Partei des
Landrats passieren muss und so gibt es
in Sonneberg in jedem anderen Landkreis
in Deutschland Mehrheiten unter
demokratischen Abgeordneten und die
können genutzt werden wenn wir uns
allerdings den Zulauf zur AFD anschauen
und die Umfragewerte sind wir vielleicht
bald von der ganz anderen Frage dann
reden wir nämlich nicht mehr über
kommunale Ebenen wie will man dann
Politik gestalten wenn die Realität nach
einer Wahl ist einfach nicht zulassen
das können wir ja ein Stück weit im
thüringischen Landtag See noch dort gibt
es eine Mehrheit ohne die AFD aber es
ist eben gerade die CDU die sich schwer
tut eine Regierung die von einem linken
Ministerpräsidenten Bodo Ramelow
angeführt wird konstruktiv in der
parlamentarischen Arbeit zu begleiten
und da sehen sie das ganze Dilemma der
CDU eine Partei die nicht in der Lage
ist wenn Sie die Wahl zwischen
Demokraten Ramelow hat und dem
Faschisten höcke sich klar zu
entscheiden mit wem man politische
Mehrheiten hat bei führen will der ist
tatsächlich nicht zu helfen und deswegen
ist es jetzt Zeit wenn ich mir das
erlauben darf als spd-generalsekretär zu
sagen für eine Richtungsstreit in der
CDU Herr Merz wollte gestern etwas
klarstellen das Gegenteil ist der Fall
das Netz ist voll mit Tweets von CDU
Abgeordneten vom Regierenden
Bürgermeister von Berlin vom Chef des
arbeitnehmerflügels von Abgeordneten und
vielen anderen mehr die empört sind die
auf die Beschlusslage der CDU Verweis
König ohne Land er wollte Dinge
klarstellen das ist jetzt noch klar
unklarer ich möchte jetzt gerne mal auf
ihre Partei und die ampelregierung
schauen ist die Stärke da AFD die
Schwäche der ampelregierung
nein die Stärke der AFD ist die
Entscheidung von Menschen im Land die
AFD zu wählen man kann unzufrieden mit
einer Regierung sein und muss deshalb
nicht AFD wählen ich bin gegen diese
Entmündigung von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
bei denen wir so tun als würden höhere
Mächte einen dazu zwingen eine großen
Teilen rechtsradikale Parteien zu gehen
die Mehrheit der Menschen im Land
richten irgendwo müssen diese
Umfragewerte herkommen und sie wissen
auch dass viele Menschen im Land nicht
zufrieden sind mit der Regierungsarbeit
also die Frage stellt sich schon ob Ihre
Partei zumindest eine Mitschuld am
Erstarken der AFD trägt
wir wissen sehr wohl wo wir auch Fehler
gemacht haben da haben wir auch hier
auch in ihrem Format regelmäßig in den
vergangenen Monaten drüber gesprochen
die Diskussion über das zustande kommen
das heizungsgesetzes und anderes mehr da
wollen und müssen wir besser werden das
ist unser eigener Anspruch als SPD als
Ampelkoalition aber nicht wegen der
Stärke der AFD sondern weil es uns darum
geht gute Politik in diesem Land zu
machen aber es wird schwer das zu tun
wenn wir von morgens bis abends nur noch
über die AFD reden Herr März hat eine
Viertelstunde gestern über die AFD
geredet an die breite Mehrheit der
Gesellschaft an deren Fragen zu lohnen
Wirtschaft Fachkräfte Einwanderung hat
er keine Worte verloren wir reden über
wenigen im Land und vergessen dabei die
vielen die sich langsam die Frage
stellen ob man hier eigentlich AFD
wählen muss damit die eigenen Probleme
auch mal besprochen werden in der
Gesellschaft und deswegen mein Appell
lassen Sie uns in der zweiten
Jahreshälfte stärker über Lohnfragen
sprechen über die Wirtschaft ankeln und
die Energiepreise bezahlbar machen da
sind demokratische Parteien richtig
aufgehoben gut dann noch eine Frage die
nichts mit der AFD zu tun hat zum
Schluss die Union sorgt ja auch für
Wirbel mit neuen Forderungen zum
härteren Umgang mit Flüchtlingen auf dem
Mittelmeer und nach flächendeckenden
Kontrollen an deutschen Außengrenzen wie
kommentieren Sie das
die Ampelkoalition kümmert sich ja ganz
konkret um die Ordnung in der
Migrationsfrage wir treiben
migrationsabkommen mit den
Herkunftsländern voran damit aus
ausreisepflichtigen jetzt auch
tatsächlicher ausreisen werden denn
ausreisen führt man nicht mit
krachledernden Reden herbei sondern
damit dass man sein politisches Handwerk
beherrscht und mit den entsprechenden
Ländern kooperiert unsere
Innenministerin hat gerade durchgesetzt
dass es erstmals eine Mehrheit in Europa
für ein solidarischen verteilmechanismus
zwischen den Ländern gibt es sind reale
Erfolge wenn es darum geht die Belastung
gemeinsam schultern zu können und es ist
ein großer Fortschritt gegenüber dem was
die Union jahrelang in der Regierung
selber nicht zustande bekommen hat also
wir arbeiten längster daran sagte
Generalsekretär der SPD Kevin Kühnert
vielen Dank für das Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen